ازمه كبرى تواجهها هوليود وتبعد 15 عاما
على اخر اضراب قام به كتاب هوليود عام
2007 وخلف خسائر كبرى قدرت وقتها بمليار
دولار عاد الكتاب الى الاضراب مره اخرى
منذ ايام من بعد فشل في التوصل الى نتائج
مرضيه في محادثاتهم مع شركات الانتاج
العملاقه والتحالف استوديوهات السينما
والتلفزيون احد عشر الف كاتب وكاتبه اي ما
يقارب
98% من اعضاء النقابه شاركوا في هذا
الاضراب وتوقفوا عن العمل وخرجوا في
تظاهرات كبرى في شوارع نيويورك وهوليوت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عما عن اسباب الادراك فكانت متنوعه من حيث
المطالب حيث طلبك كتابه برفع اجورهم
وزياده نسبه ارباحهم من شركات الانتاج من
نتفليكس وامازون وغيرها الى ان الشركات
رفضت هذا المطلب بسبب تقلص الاعلانات ومن
المطالبات التي لفتت النظر هو خطر ذكاء
الاصطناعي
وهو البرنامج الذي يعرف بقدرته على كتابه
النصوص القصيره وهو ما يهدد وظائفهم حيث
رفض الكتاب استخدام نصوصهم في تدريب
الذكاء الاصطناعي ورفضوا مراجعه ومعالجه
المسودات التي يكتبها الذكاء الاصطناعي
وطالبوا بالتوقف عن اللجوء للذكاء
الاصطناعي لكتابه نصوص والسيناريوهات
القصيره التي باتت تستهوي شركات الانتاج
كون هذه الطريقه تخفض عليهم التكاليف ساهم
الاضراب في تاخير عدد من الافلام
والمسلسلات المقرره عرضها قريبا بالاضافه
الى توقف عدد من البرامج الشهيره اما
البيت الابيض فكان قد اعلن ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يامل التوصل سريعا الى
اتفاق منصف بشان كتاب السيناريو المضربين
وذلك خوفا من تكبد المجال السمعي والبصري
خسائر بمليارات الدولارات كما حدث سابقا
على كل حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره الكاتب والسيناريس وليد خيري وليد
اهلا بكم معنا في تفاعلكم يبدو ان كتابه
وبعد ازمه تقلص الدعايات لم يكن ينقصهم
سوى دخول برنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي على
الخط الى اي مدى اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي
يهدد ويهدد عقول صناع السينما هناك
اهلا بك سيدتي بالطبع هو يخطئ يهدد
البشريه كلها الذكاء الاصطناعي وصل في في
وقت وجيز
لمراحل المتقدمه في مراحل الابحاث في
مراحل
الاصوات في مراحل الان الكتابه اعتقد ان
المطالب التي تقدم بها كتاب السنوي
الامريكان ليست مطالب تخصهم وحدهم ولكنها
تخص الكتاب في العالم لانه الخطر القادم
لا محاله فكره
الطرح الذي طرحوه بانه امتنعوا عن تبييض
المستودات التي قام بها الذكاء الاصطناعي
في فن كتابه السيناريو او تقديم سنوياتهم
الخاصه
ليستعين بها الذكاء الاصطناعي مستقبلا في
في عمليه كتابه الثانويه اعتقد هذه لابد
ان تكون هناك قوانين حازمه لانه شئنا ام
ابينا اذ لم يكن هنا قوانين فهذا الامر
سنصبح كل الكتاب في العالم وليس في امريكا
فقط
سيصبحون
جلوس في المنازل لا يعملون لان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيوفر لكل الاستوديوهات في
العالم
بتكلفه اقل بالطبع سنوات محبوكه بشكل جيد
وهذا خطر كبير جدا على كل مجالات البشريه
يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي ثوره كبيره جدا طيب
علينا ان نتعامل معاها
بوجه به استفاده دون ضرر طيب وليد المعروف
ببرنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي انه ينتج محتواه
انطلاقا من تغذيته بشريا بالبيانات اليوم
عندما يهدد كتاب هوليود بعدم معالجه
النصوص في هذا البرنامج الى مدى يهدد
فاعليه في هذه الاطار في المجال تحديدا
بالضبط هذا حقنا ككتاب هذا حق اصيل لانه
او او يكون هناك اتفاقيات مسبقه ان يكون
هناك فكره الكاتب الاصيل يعني او الكاتب
الاصلي يعني اذا انا مديت مثلا الذكاء
الاصطناعي تنسب هذه الاعمال اللي هي ككاتب
اصلي ان هزيمه مستقاه او ماخوذه من الكاتب
الاصلي الذي مد الذكاء الاصطناعي بهذه
الثانويهات او هذه التوستات او هذه
الحبكات فاعتقد هذه مساله غايه في الخطوره
وعلينا كل كتاب في العالم ان نقف مساندين
لكتاب الامريكان لانهم يطالبون بثلاث
مطالب مشروعه بنسبه من بنسبه من
بنسبه في الانتاج بمعنى انني كاتب بالاساس
العمليه الابداعيه تقوم بدايه من الكاتب
والكاتب ياخذ اجواء فقط بينما الكتابه
لسنوات طويله على شركات الانتاج
والاستديوهات مكاسب من انواع شتى العمل
الفني لسنوات طويله لشركات الطيران لمنصات
الرقميه الجديده بتدفقيه للاستوديوهات
بشكل اسوه بالاغاني والالحان الموسيقيه
يعني من حق الكتاب ان يحافظوا على حقوقهم
بشكل اصيل ودائم طيب وليد بعد شهرين من
اطلاق هذا البرنامج برنامج الاصطناعي
استخدموا 100 مليون مستخدم نشط خلال شهر
واحد الى ان مدى هذا البرنامج اليوم يهدد
كل السيناريوهات ام فقط السيناريوهات
القصيره يعني المواد المكتوبه بشكل قصير
لا طبعا في خلال شهرين حصل هذا التطاول
مفزع فانا لست ضده وبالتالي هذه حتمات
تاريخيه لكن نريد قوانين واوتو تاسس لهذا
يعني لهذا الغول الجديد هذا غول قد اغول
قد نستطيع ان نستفيد منه وقد يستطيع ان
يدور الجميع وليس في الكتابه فقط لك ان
تتخيلي ان العالم قريبا سيجلس الجميع في
منازلهم في كل المهن حتى حتى مهنتك سيدتي
نحن معرضون تماما كلنا ان نجلس في البيوت
لان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيقوم باضواء الجميع
فانا اعتقد هذه وقفه مهمه جدا جدا لكل
الصناع وليس وليد حتى نفهم الموضوع اكثر
يعني 76% من مستخدمي تشارجي بيتي يقولون
ان مواده المكتوبه عاليه الجوده يعني يعني
قيموها بشكل ملفت جدا هل بامكان هذا
البرنامج ان يكتب افلام سيناريوهات طبعا
لافلام طويله لمسلسلات
لازم تدخل بشري نعم بالطبع الفكر نعم
يستطيع جدا لنا المساله حتى خاصه في
امريكا يعني امريكا حتى لها علاقه
بالسنايه مختلفه عن السينما الاوروبيه
مثلا امريكا بتعتمد على فكره القوانين في
كتابه السيناريو امريكا تتعامل مع
السيناريو كانه كانه نص كانه مساله حسابيه
قوانين في بعد عشر دقائق يحدث كذا بعد كذا
ثم الكول ثم افضى الكول يعني بتتعمل حتى
بالذات بتتعاملوا مع السيناوي بشكل
احترافي يبدو كانه مباراه كانه حزب رياضيه
فبالتالي الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا تم امدادي
بكل هذه المواد يستطيع ان ينتج الاف وخاصه
وخاصه في انواع السنوات التي تعتمد على
التويستات والحبكات وعلى المفاجات
والاثاره اعتقد سيكون متفوقا بشكل كبير
حتى على الجانب البشري بالنهايه شكرا
جزيلا لك من القاهره حدثنا الكاتب
والسيناريست وليد خيري شكرا وليد
[موسيقى]